Vsauce Kevin here throughout history
some have given their lives to advance
scientific research because of their
efforts we can fly stave off death carry
fire in our pocket and play golf on the
moon in the decade before the Wright
brothers first flew at Kitty Hawk Otto
Lilienthal made over 2,000 flights and
gliders he designed in 1894 Auto built a
45 foot artificial hill that allowed him
to test his gliders in any direction so
he always had suitable wind conditions
on Otto's final flight the top wing of
his newest prototype broke off and he
fell 55 feet suffering fatal injuries
before he passed away his last words
we're sacrifices must be made Lilienthal
is considered the inventor of piloting
and was a direct influence on the Wright
brothers the aviation industry now
supports over 58 million jobs roughly
the entire population of Italy and
transports 3 billion passengers each
year almost twice the world population
at the time Otto made his sacrifice
Russia's Alexander Bogdanov wrote a
science fiction novel about a perfect
world on Mars in which technology has
solved all of life's problems and blood
transfusions between the young and old
extended lifespans his fiction morphed
into scientific research when he founded
the Institute for hematology and blood
transfusions in 1926 building on
centuries of slowly advancing research
he began experimenting with blood
transfusions on his friends and on
himself he believed blood transfusions
would make him immortal and claims they
improved his eyesight and cured his
baldness unfortunately his 12th
transfusion was with a student infected
with malaria and tuberculosis and
Bogdanov died
day 108 million units of blood are
collected globally each year to save
lives during surgeries and after trauma
four and a half million people in the US
alone would die annually without
life-saving blood baldness however rages
on in early 1770s Carl Vilhelm Sheila
discovered a gas he called fire air the
element we know as oxygen prior to his
discovery people believed in the
phlogiston theory which stated that
something called phlogiston a fire like
element was responsible for combustion
part of Sheila's study of compounds and
elements involved tasting them including
ones we later discovered are toxic like
lead arsenic hydrofluoric acid and
mercury leading to his death by
poisoning at the age of 43 Sheila didn't
just identify the source of combustion
he also developed a way to mass produce
phosphorus leading to the production of
matches and he described the reduction
of silver salts to metallic silver via
sunlight which is the basis of
photography which led to film which led
to video which led to YouTube which led
to Vsauce thanks Carl in the 1960s the
space race brought us technologies
ranging from artificial limbs and
firefighting equipment to solar panels
and memory foam and also a crater on the
far side of the Moon named Juan who
Chinese legends claim Juan who was the
world's first astronaut who in the 16th
century attached to kites and 47
gunpowder Rockets to a chair after a big
explosion Juan and the chair were never
seen again and as always
thanks for watching didn't work it
didn't work guys
you